hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i have
the distinct pleasure of sitting today
with irshad manji
uh she is at oxford lecturing for the
initiative for global ethics and human
rights she is
founder of the moral courage project and
author of several books including the
most recent
don't label me how to do diversity
without inflaming the culture wars
irshad welcome to darkhorse i'm so
thrilled to be here brett thanks
so tell me um you've written a book
uh don't label me how to do diversity
without inflaming the culture wars what
fun would it be if we didn't inflame the
culture wars
yeah it is fun isn't it for about five
seconds
and then you know the dopamine hit wears
off
and we continue to crave it and we
continue to chase it
and then we wind up in um
in a an abyss a sort of an ideologically
zealous abyss that um really is no fun
for anybody i don't know about you i
will tell you i am not
missing the noise of
the trump administration i love the fact
that we're actually talking about issues
not about his behavior
and i can honestly tell you that
whenever there are stories that pop up
in my feeds
about him i have zero desire
to read them i really because i i feel
like saying
um you remember what uh melania trump
was wearing on the
back of her jacket when she you know
went to see the uh
mexican kids you know uh i don't really
care do you
that's how i feel about
continuing to remain mired um
in the noise i want to move on i um
i hate to disagree with you so early in
our discussion but i
i think it's best that we just confront
the question
all right i feel a lot calmer
without the noise of trump and paying
attention to
his every word and misunderstanding and
looking for dog whistles everywhere but
i have the sense
that we now have an administration
that has uh high production values and
it knows how
to give the impression of things being
under control
and frankly i don't think it knows what
it's doing i think it is playing with
fire especially with respect to things
like the culture wars there are certain
areas where
it is clearly preferable to the approach
of the trump administration
but i don't have the sense that we are
in good hands and i do have the sense
that
most of the people that i talk to
have breathed a sigh of relief and that
is going to leave
um the foxes in charge of the hen house
without anyone even paying attention to
what's happening uh
to to the birds yeah and you know brett
i think we may be having a heated
agreement here
um i don't disagree with you at all
about this and i certainly did not mean
to suggest
that um you know all is well uh in
america land now
not at all what i simply wanted to
convey
was that um you know the the fun
of mudslinging um wears off quickly
and now it's time to scrutinize um you
know what this
uh biden administration biden harris
administration
uh is doing and i have to tell you i i
do think
that particularly on the harris side um
we are going to get an inflaming of the
culture wars
um i don't trust
that she appreciates
how diverse this country is and by
diverse i mean
diversity of viewpoint not just
diversity of demographics i think that
she is an opportunist she has shown
herself to be
and that she will curry favor with any
anybody in the progressive camp
who wants to inflame the culture wars
so we're not out of the woods by any
stretch
uh but it's just now we can begin
talking
details rather than merely
commenting on trump's latest outrage
yes i feel like we are in the woods
having been pumped full of valium so
that we're not even aware
that there might be you know things that
we need to pay attention to
now i regard harris as a perfectly
cynical
entity who will do anything that
advances her cause and i regard biden a
little bit differently i see him as sort
of
planktonically corrupt that he's been
carried along with the culture of
corruption in the democratic party
for the better part of his career and
that he has now landed in this position
of tremendous power and he's still
behaving
in a planktonic fashion that is to say
he's
uh going the direction that the winds
blow on
on his side of the aisle and what i
meant to imply
uh as i said that we were disagreeing
and you challenged me and said we are in
heated agreement which i also think is
likely
is that the the day that donald trump
was elected and everybody
was in shock i had the feeling i had a
bizarre
feeling of relief not at his election
because i wasn't relieved at that though
i would have been
terrified in a different way if hillary
clinton had been elected
but i had the sense that suddenly an
entire
class of people was wide awake for the
first time
in recent memory that the election of
donald trump was so far outside of what
was expected
that all kinds of people who are not
aware
of how dangerous the political machines
have become especially
on the blue team were processing
information
directly for the first time and trying
to understand what planet they were
living on
and that that was a very healthy
phenomenon now i think it degraded into
something over the course of the trump
administration
that was very unhealthy but being awake
is a prerequisite to figuring out
how we lost the thread and how we can
possibly
return to rational governance and i am
now troubled by watching people
return to a kind of complacency because
what's on the news is now so familiar
looking
that it seems like somebody must be in
charge when in fact
i i don't think that's even remotely the
case
um so i want to pick up on your point
about
who if anybody is in charge but let me
rewind for a second
um you know in a sense i
hold myself uh uh
accountable miniscule way
uh i'm one person but i remember um
i was teaching at new york university uh
back in 2009
and it was during that time that i
undertook a fairly extensive tour of
the heartland uh and uh with my first
book uh the trouble with islam today
wait when you say heartland do you mean
the american heartland the american
heartland excuse me um
but just to be just to be clear you live
in canada at the moment no
no i'm sorry i haven't misread that
i'm a citizen of canada uh but
i have lived and worked in the united
states for almost 15 years now
and um so at this time i was teaching at
nyu
and i undertook as i say this uh tour of
the american heartland with
with my book my first book about the
need for reform in islam
and i was your first book sorry your
first book is called the trouble with
islam today is that correct correct
correct that's right um
and i speak as a muslim in writing that
book the subtitle is a muslims call for
reform in her faith
i was i was surprised and i didn't know
what to do with the fact that
at various turns in that tour
i would hear the question
why do they hate us but here's the thing
brett
the people asking that question were not
asking about why
muslims hate americans they were asking
why do east coast people
hate us in the heartland
and when i got back to nyu
i sat down with the dean of my
department
and a he at the time and he asked me
um so what was it like how much
islamophobia
did you have to ward off i said to him
none that i was able to notice
uh notice he didn't say
did you encounter islamophobia no how
much
did you encounter right and that was
you know it's just such an affirmation
of what i was hearing from people in the
heartland
the frankly humiliation
to which they've been subjected by the
overly educated
who are really in so many ways
under-educated
um you know for the last 20 30
years and so i've
long understood where um
you know the the resentment
the cultural grievance has come from and
i'm the first to say they're not all
racists
and the more the more we fall into that
trap
now that the familiar ethos of a biden
harris administration
you know is um is is back in play
the more we fall into that trap
the more we create the very thing
that we say we oppose
i agree we are going to we are going to
resurrect
racism by virtue of falsely demonizing
people
claiming that they have it when in fact
it isn't in their minds which doesn't
mean that they don't have
ignorance right there is ubiquitous
ignorance we are all ignorant of
the experience of people who come from
different places but that ignorance
unless it is willful doesn't
cross over into what we ought to be
calling racism exactly
exactly the real crime if i may say is
not ignorance it's
in curiosity a lack of curiosity
very well said yes that's that's the
thing and the fact is
your your experience that you describe
of
a not experiencing islamophobia
yourself as a muslim b
not encountering racism that
you know the blue team swears is lurking
in
every white mind this
is very similar to my experience i i'm i
come
from a now nearly
dead tradition of uh left intellectuals
and uh as i have been
rejected by people who are nominally on
my side of the political spectrum and i
have traveled extensively
amongst the people who are accused of
racism so regularly
they're told they live in flyover states
that they're deplorable
it is amazing how infrequently one runs
into anything that you would actually
apply the label
racism to and it is also interesting how
many of the values
that uh in in my very progressive
household the one in which i grew up
the those values are now being defended
by many on the center right in a way
that i never expected to see
um but unless you travel across the
lines
uh that we're told you needn't bother
with you don't discover that the story
about the others is just simply false
you know this is the great uh tragedy of
labels
it's not the fact that labels themselves
are inaccurate after all you can label
me a muslim and you would be right
you could label me a woman and you would
be right it's the baggage
the assumptions that go with those
labels
and i'm uh i'm
constantly struggling with
how we are going to move beyond those
assumptions
in a time in which we all live we are
immersed
in the kinds of technologies that
frankly don't
incentivize the kind of thing we're
doing right now
openly engaging right immersed in
technologies that are deliberately
designed to amp up
our emotions and from uh you're the
first person to
to recognize this being an evolutionary
biologist from a biological perspective
the
easiest emotion to have is fear
yes i think that's uh literally right
and not because
uh of it is a cognitive bias built into
us
because of effectively the same logic
that results in
your fire alarm going off when you burn
toast which is
a fire alarm that goes off for burnt
toast can still save your life one that
assumes that a lot of smoke is toast
related
may miss an actual fire and you may get
trapped by it so
your your fight or flight reflex is
built to be oversensitive and to the
extent that there are
algorithmic reasons to trigger it
because it gets you very engaged
you know and that serves someone's
economic interest it causes us all to be
jerked around
when you know i mean let's put it this
way you you
describe yourself as being interested
in navigating correctly navigating
issues of
what we might otherwise call diversity
equity and inclusion
without involved in without getting
involved in what we
recognize as the culture war you are not
absolutely alone in this squadron you
are uh
you are friends with chloe valderri so
she's a mutual friend of ours
and i would say that you are both
interested in figuring out
you know sorting the wheat from the
chaff in this area rather than just
pretending that there is no issue of
diversity equity and inclusion
right and you know i i share that belief
with you there is something to be
navigated and unfortunately both polls
are wrong about it it's not that we
don't have a problem
right but it is also not that you know
white supremacy is
uh ubiquitous in in america and the west
and it has to be
stamped out along with patriarchy and
all of those
uh false uh assertions
i have to yeah well you know uh this um
the constant refrain of white supremacy
um it's so sad for all kinds of reasons
but one of the big reasons for me
is that uh first of all you know my
family
are refugees from uganda in east africa
we were booted out
by a black man idi amin who
decided that africa belongs
only to blacks um
well guess what folks uh my family had
been
in uganda for three generations
uh we did not know any other country
we did not have a passport to india or a
passport to britain
uganda was our country
um but you know the the the
very legitimate aspiration to liberation
in the various african colonies
devolved as aspirations often do
into a fever called pan-africanism
and that is when you get the dogma and
dogma by definition
is exclusionary so no wonder
that you know a military dictator
could tell other people of color
you do not belong here and
part of what is so frustrating for
somebody
who has been born in a completely
different uh
segment of the world coming to the
united states
is that even those who decry
western imperialism or who
uh you know castigate
others for quote centering whiteness
they themselves don't recognize that
these impulses to exclude
are human they are
endemically human and that if you're
gonna go around
preaching to others to check their bias
the question becomes what bias of yours
are you checking role model that show
that
and that's again not what we see so in a
way
brett i feel like this whole uh
cultural moment uh sort of focusing on
diversity equity inclusion and the like
is missing something huge a huge
opportunity and the opportunity is this
right now it's as if there are two rival
teams on the field
one used to wear the jersey called
powerful
and the other used to wear the uniform
uh
labeled powerless now those jerseys are
being swiped uh swapped out okay they're
being
traded but you have the same game
we have the opportunity right now to
change the us
against them game through
diversity equity and inclusion and that
is
not what we are doing we're replicating
the game
right we are replicating the game it's
not as if this isn't a known
pattern i mean i sort of feel like there
are places where the right lesson is
encoded
right there are things you will find in
orwell that are absolutely central to
our moment
you know the who covered this particular
one meet the new boss
same as the old boss and the idea is we
have this
tendency to valorize the oppressed which
is understandable but the problem is
your point is exactly right there is
a quadrant of human nature that acts
in a particular way based on its
opportunities once it gains power
and so to the extent that we view the
oppressed as
more deserving they may be more
deserving but at the point that you
transfer who's powerful
to them they behave in the same ways
because guess what this had nothing to
do
with their particular genes creating
particular defects of cognition
this has to do with game theory the
powerful tend to behave this way unless
you build systems in which it doesn't
pay
if you build those systems we can behave
much better and many of us have seen
that world we have
lived in these circumstances where
frankly race has been sidelined
and we've seen how well it works and
it's very
frustrating to have the
functional world that we might live in
prototyped
all around the landscape but when it
comes time to say
actually here's how we ought to
structure things so that race is not a
dominant predictor of your
well-being for example we end up shouted
down
by those who are playing a game that
whether they are cynical
the game is cynical right exactly
leveraging power in order to get limited
resources
you know making hay while the sun shines
and this is
you know this was a disaster a hundred
years ago
but it's actually an existential threat
now because if you play that game
in a world where people are as
thoroughly armed as they are
and in which these tendencies are so
amplified by technologies that we did
not evolve with
this is going to result in a this being
a very short ride
so we have a limited amount of time to
fix this it's not like
you know we can go through another
couple genocides and uh
then figure it out actually the time is
now
right right um it's so interesting um
i wanted to pick up on something you
just said about how
uh you know we've we've seen where this
can lead
right um i have a very good friend who
wrote a fantastic piece about the
re-segregation that is happening
in various schools across the country to
kids
you know third and fourth graders being
um
sort of uh divided up physically divided
up uh
in sort of the white quadrant
the you know black quadrant the bipark
uh
quadrant etc etc and
um one of the people who
advocates this kind of thing is
was the bridesmaid to the friend who
wrote about
who wrote scathingly about this and one
of my friends
saw that her former bridesmaid was on
board with this divvying up of kids she
asked her former bridesmaid
what gives what happened and
the educator who you know advocates this
kind of uh
resegregation said well i'm proud
to be working at a school that is
willing to try
new things to try old things really to
try
how does it not occur to her that we
did try this and it was bad
how does an educator not realize that
this is
not a new thing it's an old thing
yes tell me how that happens brett well
i i wish i knew
and you know of course i um
rather famously lived this exact
phenomenon as i watched
my college embrace segregation
i did the obvious thing which was to
point out that this wasn't a good idea
and i became you know the sort of symbol
for white supremacy on my campus because
i was against
segregation i mean that that is such a
bizarre
uh experience to go through right if you
had told me
at 35 that that was going to happen to
me
you know on the cusp of
50 right that i was going to be
demonized as a racist for
fighting segregation i would have
thought you completely bonkers
right likewise if you had told me 10
years ago
that we would be having a fight over
whether or not
there was a sexual binary that was uh
supported by scientific evidence i mean
this
couldn't possibly be a more secure
conclusion has nothing to do with humans
it goes back 500 million years in our
lineage alone
right how could we possibly find
ourselves fighting over that
or the idea that in mathematics we would
be fighting over whether or not two plus
two indeed equals four
in some fundamental way like how did we
allow the very basic rules for
memory or extrapolation
to be taken from us
so now let me ask a kind of a
provocative question okay to the both of
us
and i myself don't yet have an answer
by uh literally because the question is
this
what are we missing what are you and i
not getting that so many others
get i'd really i'm very open
yeah to exploring this
well so let me say i want to be careful
because i feel like
there are certain things that we could
say almost for sure okay
we're missing 90 of the story
you and me okay or that that's because
we're doing well
right the fact that it you know we might
be getting 10 of it is is
par for the course actually that doesn't
mean
that the object that sounds like the one
you're describing
actually exists because i don't think we
are
missing it i think the point is we have
been invited to a game
that were we to say you know what we're
probably powerless to stop the game
so we might as well play to win right if
you wanted to win
the diversity equity and inclusion game
so that at the point that it collapses
which i would argue is
absolutely inevitable when that game
collapses
you know you could have three homes
maybe if you played your cards right
right um and so the question is
not what are we missing the question is
why would we fail to play the game
when the alternative is to effectively
play
cassandra and to warn of something
that's coming
and have it not create the impact that
could prevent it
well in part i know why
i refuse to play by the rules of the
game
um one of the reasons there are many
but one of the reasons i refuse to play
by the rules
is that um as i mentioned you know my
family and i are refugees to this part
of the world
and i can say without a shadow of a
doubt
that it has been uh our good fortune
to wind up here um every morning
before i pull my sorry butt out of bed
i think uh god
i am a person of faith uh
i thank god that you know we wound up in
a part of the world
where as somebody with all of my labels
um as somebody who nonetheless
has been given the opportunities
and has recognized them
as opportunities and has
taken the opportunities to
develop a voice and to become
something of a thought leader um
i i really believe brett that most
people in our society have
those opportunities i see
how you know students of color for
example
in uh urban centers where i've i've
taught
are being pumped with the narrative
that not only are they victims but now
quite apart from their skin color now
they are also along with white kids
fragile
so that even being exposed
to a different perspective one that
challenges
the narrative that they're being you
know filled with
is harming them and a lot of these kids
actually don't feel harm but they're
thinking to themselves well
if i'm supposed to be harmed then
i guess i better act that way because
that's what's expected of me
so we're creating these false
divisions and intentions
and for what for the adults
to build stature upon
this pile of falsifications
um i agree with a lot that you said i
want to make sure to go back to
the beginning of it because i think the
central point may be this one
so if the question is why given that we
could
play the game to win and so many seem to
be doing it
why would we take the risk of not
playing that game
and your
initial answer was that you know how
lucky you are
i would say this matches my experience
exactly
on my worst day i know how lucky i am
right this is the good fortune
of these opportunities is
almost impossible to overstate even as
dire as i think our global situation is
and as concerned as i am
that my children may see civilization
come apart
i know that you know that effectively
uh even people of modest means at the
moment
live like kings at the level of their
their somatic well-being and that
therefore
the sense of privation is
largely a trick of the mind and in fact
i think i know exactly what trick of the
mind it
is evolutionarily speaking
one finds opportunity if they feel
that they are jeopardized or being
shortchanged by the world
so no matter how lucky you are you are
wired to be dissatisfied
and therefore to figure out what
opportunities may be lurking that you
hadn't noticed before
and that natural tendency not
to feel you know you can feel satisfied
temporarily that's a reward for having
discovered some
patch of goodness but you can't be
stably satisfied
or you will be demotivated and so
selection has programmed us
to be easily dissatisfied and
our culture has taken ruthless advantage
of this
because advertisers the way they
motivate you to spend money that you
would not otherwise spend or to spend it
in ways that you would not otherwise
spend it
is to cause you is essentially to tell
you something's wrong
and we have the solution to it and
whether that's a deodorant
or a car or a new phone
whatever it may be the idea is they have
to create dissatisfaction in order to
get your money
and so effectively from the moment we
get up in the morning
so the moment we go to bed at night we
are being bombarded by messages
that say you could be better right you
could be happier
you could be more satisfied and here's
the way to do it
and i think frankly it's created a an
epidemic of dissatisfaction which then
functions almost like
greed and so maybe this is a long way of
saying that i think you're
identifying feeling lucky as the reason
that you
refuse to play a game that you could
probably uh
be excellent at that would be very
rewarding financially i think
i wonder if we were to look at all of
the people who appear to be refusing to
play that game
whether we would find uh gratitude
disproportionately
represented there very interesting
uh you see um so i know i'm lucky
um it was through no doing of my own
um that you know i was and along with my
family of course expelled
to a materially wealthier part of the
world
um when we arrived in the country canada
i'm talking about you know we were given
our winter coats
along with some temporary housing and
i'd like to say having fled civil war
uh that at one in the same time we got
peace and fleece
you know uh if that is not lucky i don't
know what
is and yet what was not
lucky i don't think but you tell me is
that
you know i went to a public school where
questions were were encouraged
where i was not penalized for asking
questions
when where i was penalized for asking
questions was my islamic religious
school
and i got booted out at the age of 14
and
because my mother was smart enough to
not
order me to go back and beg for
forgiveness since you know what was i to
be forgiven for
being curious uh but because of her
you know sort of calm and rationality
around all of this
she asked me by the way now that you're
no longer welcome there every saturday
what are you going to do with all that
time and she said i want you to be
thoughtful about it
that vote of confidence made me want to
live up to her expectations
and that's why i geeked out and went to
the public
library and so it is indeed lucky
that i grew up in a society where we
have such things
as public libraries but here's what i'm
struggling with
that is the society we have today
and yet children are being told
that they can't handle
figure figuring things out for
themselves
that they can't handle the welter of
information that is out there
that they need to follow
you know uh what is right and what is
wrong and that we as adults will tell
you what that is now
of course that's an issue that's taught
you know that's that's uh
timeless right the the authority of the
adult
but we're in a situation now where the
very
advantages that we have
living in a relatively free still
relatively democratic society
are being framed as
evils so if
if a country with the wealth
in all kinds of ways the wealth that we
have
is uh nothing
but a series of hurdles for young people
because that's what they are told
how how does it get any better it's it's
the paradigm that
the the the the toxic negativity of this
paradigm
that it seems to me is just
self-fulfilling
it's literally a race to the bottom
it's a it's a race to the bottom being
initiated by people who have
no idea what the bottom is like they do
not know where they are
right about that they don't know so
the incredibly tragic thing about this
moment is that
because we have been so successful at
solving
so many problems people don't realize
what
happens that if you remove the solutions
because you're pursuing
some objective whether it's a phantom or
it's real
you remove the solutions and those
problems will re-emerge and
we've had it too easy which doesn't mean
that opportunity has been well
distributed in fact i think it has
concentrated in a way that's completely
unacceptable but
to kill the goose that lays the golden
eggs
because you don't realize that that's in
fact what it is
is a terrible tragedy and unfortunately
those of us who do understand that it
can be
much much worse than it is are finding
ourselves powerless to make that point
there's something so intoxicating about
the idea
that the problems are obvious the
solutions are known we just simply have
to
force civilization to them that has made
those with this power that is
accumulating completely deaf
to the warnings that they absolutely
urgently need to hear
why do you think today it is
so much more difficult to
inject nuance into into analyses and
have that taken seriously
i mean there are multiple factors i know
but do you think there is something
overarching
yes uh more or less i do and i think
that the something is
corruption and i mean corruption in a
general sense there's of course
a narrow sort of political corruption
that occurs but we have a general
culture of corruption that has resulted
in
powerful forces unhooking the mechanisms
by which we would figure out
what is true because it is inconvenient
for this industry or that industry or
this coalition
so the ability to shut down
an inquiry that leads in an inconvenient
direction has now swept across the board
and so the institutions
i don't think in general it is that
people once understood and now they
don't
i think that what happened was the
governance structure
writ large including journalism
and the culture of people that
that adjust the way society functions
was
more or less informed by a more or less
factual understanding of the world
through a process that yes was very
noisy but wasn't perversely incentivized
and the i know
from looking at what takes place inside
of science
that effectively the mechanism that
figures out what's true
and tells us what it is irrespective of
it if it's what whether we want
irrespective of whether it is what we
want to hear that mechanism is no longer
functional and
so what that means is we are living in a
kind of a giant he said she said
world which is all about factions
getting ahead of each other and not
about the thing that actually ought to
unite us which is the truth
of the precariousness of our position
the necessity that we figure out
how to preserve the system as we have it
to fix its defects
as is possible and to move forward
through time
aware that the real jeopardy may come
from
outside right we could face for example
a carrington event that would take out a
large portion
of let's say a third you know the of the
grid the electrical grid for
north america would create a very
serious nuclear hazard
because nuclear reactors depend on power
in order not to melt down
etc that's a threat that's not a
political question
that's a question we ought to be focused
on because of the fragility of the
system we've structured
and all people ought to be united in
looking at that and saying well
that ought to be a high priority but of
course it's on nobody's radar
because it doesn't fit with the paradigm
of demonizing the other
and arguing that in fact they are the
problem we are the solution it's time to
give us power and all of the
the games that are usually played so yes
i would say the collapse of the
institutions that are supposed to inform
us is at the core of this
um what would you say is the reason for
the collapse
where did that start um
well without being too specific about it
i would say
that there is a there are a set
of processes that are uniquely capable
but are also fragile by nature right so
science is such a thing
science is the best mechanism
we have for figuring out what is true
there will be tweaks to the way we do it
but in general i think we've landed on
the best mechanism
for robustly increasing our
understanding over time
it is not tolerant to being plugged into
market forces
right it can't be in the same room with
them it needs distance
and so it's independent it needs it
needs a firewall
and so by not firewalling science and by
saying well okay market forces are great
they figure out
what's better and what's worse so let's
just plug the market into them we'll
figure out
who the best professors are we'll figure
out what the right experiments are we'll
figure out what the questions are we
ought to address by doing that through
market forces
we've effectively taken the trappings of
science
and put them onto uh
economic phenomena and so the market
may be very interested in telling us
what we want to hear it may be
interested in flattering us
and it may be reluctant to warn us
because that's kind of a bummer and it
you know it doesn't sell cars so we
uh you know we took our our best asset
and
we threw it in the shed with some
chemicals that
uh it can't withstand and then we're
surprised
that it isn't working right and it's not
the only one of these you know we have
uh market forces impacting the way our
courts run
we have market forces uh thoroughly
infused
in our journalistic mechanism the first
draft of history is being
written by forces that are competing for
our attention
and uh for which truth is at best
secondary
um so all of these things i think are
downstream
of this uh
i you know i'm very enthusiastic about
markets i believe they are
uniquely capable but they are not the
right tool for anything and everything
they are the right tool for certain
things and they need to be kept away
from other things and because we didn't
draw that line
i believe our institutions are um
in collapse um
so um would you say well okay
oh my gosh there's so much i want to ask
you here
you use the word collapse
them's fighting words you didn't just
say decline
collapse collapse is that effect
accompli
probably um you know i would love to see
the university system resurrected
so that it could play its proper role
but i also have lived inside of it
enough to know that you know you can go
field by
field and nine out of ten of them
are uh basically lobotomized
right and you know you can see this very
clearly
in the covet epidemic
right kovid has taken fields that we
rarely pay close attention to
in the public and it has put them center
stage
and so this is like you know a uh
a random test of how healthy academia
is right okay suddenly we're listening
to virologists and epidemiologists
let's see how credible are they well
they are circling the wagons around for
example the idea
that covet 19 must have emerged from
nature unaltered and couldn't possibly
have emerged from
the laboratory in wuhan that was
studying these very things
and they have gone about demonizing
people who said wait a minute actually
there are at least four different kinds
of evidence that suggest
otherwise and if you scratch
the surface and you dig a little deeper
you discover that actually
in part there are perverse incentives
economic in nature
that would cause these fields to circle
the wagons
around what is increasingly clearly
a false consensus
and so you know what i would say is
that's not a coincidence
we you know history chose
a field or two at random for us to check
how well our institutions are doing and
what we found is that the people that we
need
to be completely independent of politics
and economics at this moment
are behaving in a completely political
and economically motivated way
right and my contention is you're going
to find that across the map
right any field you tune into is very
likely to have these
dynamics the you know your best bet for
places where
it isn't are places where nothing is at
stake right the closer that a field is
to uh economic phenomena medicine for
example the more corrupt it tends to be
um so yeah i think um
sadly you can't just if
you fixed the connection to the market
of the university system tomorrow it
would take
decades for the system to recover
effectively it would have to clear
people whose for whom the corruption is
endemic in their minds
and replaced them with people who came
from
uh a place of mental independence
and it's it's not a short-term solution
but we don't have that time you're
suggesting
uh you know it's very hard to put a time
frame but
yeah carrington event that i mentioned
that could happen any day
right we would get minimal warning and
there's very little we can do about it
uh we it is far too early to say that
covet 19
came from the lab in wuhan but let's put
it this way
it is certainly possible to have
increased the transmissibility
and the devastation that a particular
virus
is capable of and for it to have escaped
a lab so we were playing
exactly the game that could have caused
kovat 19
whether it did or it did not doesn't
matter we were playing that game
because we were being foolish because we
misunderstood
the comparison between the risk of
something like that emerging from nature
and the risk that we would in fact
create it and uh it would escape
our control so we know that we were
playing that dumb game
and why were we playing it because
of it's very directly a question of
economics
you had a small number of people who
successfully persuaded
the funding apparatus to throw many
millions of dollars
at this question because they
effectively spooked it
right they told us this is coming we're
either going to know it before it
happens or we're going to be caught with
our pants down
and you know we were we were spooked
into creating this hazard
so um yeah i'm
we don't have this time now you and i
both
have experienced a great deal of luck
and we are tuned in
on the idea of luck and it's possible
that humanity will get very very lucky
and although we are running
unconscionable risks on a daily basis
that we will
continue to flip coins and have them
come up heads
and that if we started to right the ship
now we would uh we would make it
on the other hand it does seem like we
need
some other plan in the short term
something that can behave reasonably
even if our institutions are not
uh functioning well so
brett i'm gonna confide something to you
um
and therefore to your listeners
obviously um
part of what i struggle with on a daily
basis
is my own faith in humanity
and you know having studied enough
neuroscience and social psychology to
recognize
just how uh manipulated
uh assuming we even have consciousness
how manipulated our conscious selves are
by the easily threatened ego how
short-term how greedy uh
how spooked as you put it we can be
and behave in highly you know
disproportionate ways as a result
it makes me wonder whether
um oh god i hate to say this
okay here we go whether whether we even
deserve to survive
um yeah well let me help you with that i
think i can
um we definitely deserve to survive
um because you know we're stuck in the
following
in the following predicament all
of the worst atrocities in history
are downstream from programs
that are evolutionary in nature but all
of the best stuff
that we are capable of is to in other
words
humans are effectively caught between
multiple possibilities
we can be terrible we can engage in
warfare
and genocide and we can be completely
deaf to the humanity of others
and treat them as objects or worse as
entities
deserving of torment or we can be
tremendously compassionate and
innovative and hell-bent
on creating beauty and
insight all of those things are features
of humans
and i think wise people have repeatedly
happened on the recognition
that it isn't one or the other that we
the question is really will we create
the circumstances
that bring out the remarkable things
that only humans are capable of
or will we allow
those structures to break down and
return us
to this natural state of
uh conflict in which our our innovative
capacity is put
towards uh bigger and more frightening
weapons and you know torture mechanisms
and so i guess what i would say is
if we can recognize that both things are
on the table and we can
understand that we are actually morally
obligated to create
the conditions that bring out the best
in humans
then we will have earned
our place and if we
ignore that obligation and play these
petty games
and destroy ourselves in some sense
you know that will be on the collective
us for missing the opportunity
and to me the thing that is most tragic
is
that the people who wouldn't have done
that are condemned to the same
fate i want to see as as many people as
possible
recognize that human beings can be
terrific creatures
if they have the conditions conducive to
it and then
which they themselves have to create
though the conditions conducive to it
exactly but the point is look i can name
many many people who would no doubt take
us
in you know we can't say that it would
work but they would seek to take us in
the correct direction
to liberate as many humans as possible
to give them the tools
to innovate positively to generate
insight beauty all of those things
there's no shortage of those people they
are
on a ship with lots of people who are
insisting on playing
this other game and demonizing and
tormenting and torturing
and um i hate that those two
groups are stuck with each other because
you know there's only so much the wise
people can do
to divert our course to the obvious one
but i also see that as a predicament
that for me at least fills every day
with meaning doesn't it just absolutely
you you know you get out of bed knowing
what you're here on this earth to do
right yeah and and it's you know it's
certainly an interesting puzzle how the
heck can you
steer a ship like this one you know
where even is the helm never mind that
nobody's manning it where even is it
right is it are we going to get there
through podcast land i i don't know
well you know i think i think
enlightened uh
rich forms of media
have to play a part because again you
know we're
we're immersed in um uh
multimedia today and and it would be
silly i think
to suggest that you know any of us is
immune
to being influenced or shaped um you
know by
by the media that we consume but you um
you're you're i'm not going to call it
optimism because i think you're smarter
than that
in fact i know you're smarter than that
but but you seem full
of hope which is not the same thing as
optimism
hope suggests that we do have agency
should we choose to use it and use it
wisely obviously
and you remind me in that way of uh
of my younger self when i was
traveling you know the world uh speaking
to muslims and others about the need for
reform
in my faith of islam and i remember
being told
by all kinds of people some well-meaning
some more malevolent that um
you know give it up manji if martin
luther king jr had a dream you have a
pipe dream
you know violence is baked into
islam and uh this may be
your way of denying that in fact you're
an atheist
but better that you come out of closet
now as godless
then you know waste your breath and
everybody else's
on something that simply can't happen
and
trust me when i say that i took a lot of
time
to think about those sorts of comments
i sat with myself for many an hour uh
really you know exposing myself to to
questions uh
about whether in fact i do believe why
do i believe and so forth
but the bottom line is this um that was
you know 16
17 18 years ago today
um i hear from young muslims
a whole new generation and then even the
generation after that
who say you know i can have
conversations like this
with my parents with the elders
of my community um even with theologians
because people like you opened the door
and once once that door is open it can't
be closed now whether i choose
as a young muslim to walk through that
door
that you know that is my choice to make
but i couldn't walk through it if it
wasn't already
open i remember
when i was teaching at the university of
southern california
uh around about uh four years ago
um i held an event called
forbidden questions about islam
forbidden questions and the whole point
was to invite people's most burning
questions that they felt they couldn't
turn anywhere else
to ask and at least i would assure them
can't say this for the audience but i
would assure them that they will not be
immediately judged for having those
questions let's get it all out on the
table
not only was that event
allowed to proceed but afterwards
i spent four hours in the atrium of the
building
engaging with a large group of young
muslim women almost all of whom wore
hijab
okay the head covering and who couldn't
get enough
of this honest discourse
and it it reminded me
that uh to to quote uh edmund burke
uh and i'll quote him you know directly
i won't try to sanitize it
no man makes a bigger mistake than he
who does nothing because he does only
little
it's um it's so true
that we still have that agency
all right shall we uh there's something
i'm i'm dying to talk to you about
and i unfortunately this is going to
require a little bit of a disclaimer
here because
i think i know what the question is but
i don't really have the position
from which to ask it and so i need to
say a little bit about my own history
um before i ask a question that uh i
think we will both agree
is not my place to ask so
your story and mine are not remotely
similar but there is an interesting
parallel
so i i read about you the the story that
you recount earlier of having been
kicked out of madrasa for asking too
many questions
or the wrong kind of questions so here's
my story
i grew up in a very secular home
we were culturally jewish but there was
nothing invested in uh
in judaism as a religion
and as my friends were you know many of
my friends were jewish
getting bar mitzvahed and the like or
heading towards it and i
felt a bit left out what was this thing
and in fact my best friend when i was
quite young
uh aaron came from a household
to be honest i couldn't tell you i still
don't know what they actually believe
but i know that they were observant
right so i spent many seders at their
house
and uh you know i got to see what a
uh a non-secular jewish home looked like
and so in any case at some point i
actually asked
to go to schule and to
figure out what this thing was and i
went
and i was thoroughly disappointed and
the reason that i was disappointed
i was allowed to ask questions but the
answers
were nonsense and i knew they were
nonsense and so
what was the point why you know school
was already a problem for me i wasn't
any good at it
and that revealed something about what
was wrong with it
and here i was choosing to go to more
school and when i asked questions that i
knew were perfectly good questions the
answers that came back were gobbledygook
and so i left and in some ways i think
that
uh that's a bit of a tragic story
because
you know that was uh it was just i
dipped my toe in the water somewhere and
had i done it in some
you know in a different building in a
different part of town i might have had
a different experience but
what i got i took to be representative
and i paid very little attention to
judaism
[Music]
directly from that point forward until i
started to realize my error
as you know as an adult
in any case it leads me here
there is a question about why
islam is the way it is and there is no
doubt there is a tremendous amount
of violence inherent to the doctrine
in the quran but you could say the very
same thing about about the torah
it's in there too and so there's a
concept
which i have played with i've also heard
eric has a formulation of it and the
idea is that there's a distinction
between these two traditions and the
distinction
is about the mechanism through which
um religious dogma is
updated that judaism effectively has
a um a living rabbinical
tradition that interprets the doctrine
in light of modern realities
right so we don't spend so much time on
the details of moses's laws of war which
are perfectly abhorrent
because it's not relevant and in fact it
is in conflict with the modern world so
it is de-emphasized by
a living tradition and that
in islam and you correct me if i have
this wrong
in islam there is actually a prohibition
effectively
against update and i don't know how much
you know about my
uh evolutionary conjecture about what
religion is
but what i have said is that religions
are literally false but metaphorically
true
metaphorically true means that we take
things that actually put a lineage at
advantage
and encode them in stories that are not
factual
but that result in adaptive behavior
that mechanism is subject to capture
right so the story of jesus flipping
over the the money changers tables in
the temple is one of a rebellion against
capture effectively um uh martin luther
having challenged indulgences in the
catholic church is a challenge to a kind
of capture
and that islam has encoded
resistance to capture in
the pro-prohibition against profits
after
muhammad how am i doing so far
um i i think you're getting the broad
strokes
uh quite right there are some
interpretive uh
issues here that you know i'll certainly
talk about in a second
but so far i'm i hear you okay
so the question is every tradition
has uh what i would call an analog to
virus protection the way you might have
virus protection on your computer
religious uh texts have a way to prevent
people from capturing the voice of god
and using it for their own
benefit and preventing new profits would
be one such mechanism
um and you know a rabbinical class
that uh has license to shut down
bad schools of thought for example might
be another um
but the question is a
is there something to the idea that
in the ancient world there was a great
deal of brutality
that brutality has traveled more easily
through time
with islam because its particular
version
of resistance to bad ideas prevents
update and therefore modernity is a
bigger leap
is there does that strike you as correct
it strikes me as potentially correct now
let me explain why potentially
and and let me start by saying that um
if if i believed that islam
as a faith or a religion was
incapable of reinterpretation
i could not have integrity as
as a muslim i would i would have to
leave
the religion but i don't believe that
because uh it's one thing
uh how how the practitioners
of a religion on the whole behave
is obviously a demonstration
of what they believe but it is
not a demonstration of what is possible
and so for example uh most muslims don't
even know
brett that the quran islam scripture
contains three times as many verses
calling on muslims to think ask
questions analyze rethink
and decide for themselves than verses
that tell us
to just submit to this or that three
times as
many verses most muslims
have and i'm talking about globally now
have never been exposed to the idea
that i picked up at the public library
namely that islam has its own tradition
of independent thinking of
of creative reasoning and dissent and
debate
and yeah reinterpretation it's a uh it's
a
a tradition known as each dihad not
jihad
although even that word does not uh mean
violence
um it's the connotation that militants
have gave given it that you know now uh
conjures up violence that are in our
heads
but ichtyhad is all about struggling
with
the complexity of the world and
there are plenty of you know again power
hungry theologians
some would say that's a redundant phrase
i know but power hungry theologians
who would argue that you know the irshad
manji's of this world would like you to
believe
that um that jihad is open to all
muslims but no it's not you need a
certain amount of scholarship
and even lesser known scholars have
pointed out
that the one right under
you know the umbrella of ichti had that
all muslims have
is to decide for themselves what
scholars to follow so that
those scholars who argue that ichtihad
is something that all muslims need to
exercise
and have both the responsibility and the
right to exercise
one can choose to follow those scholars
not simply
the louder more institutionally backed
who hang on to their power by telling us
you cannot think for yourself
right so all of this is simply to say
that the fact is that it is we
muslims who need reform
and in reforming ourselves we thereby
reform islam but islam itself has the
raw materials
to uh overcome what has been abused in
its name
i i'll just finish up by saying saying
something that
you know i remember when bill clinton
was president more than once i i heard
him say and i was a you know
pretty young at the time and i i was
struck by this that there is nothing
wrong with america
that cannot be fixed by what is right
with america
[Music]
and i must tell you that that is
exactly how i view my relationship with
islam
beautiful beautiful so this is actually
um
better than i had hoped because while i
think there's something to be evaluated
in this question of what the update
mechanisms are and what circumstances
they find themselves in are
are there certain ones that just by
happenstance happen to work better in
modernity and the like
but the second part of what i wanted to
ask you about
is that i am by no means
a scholar of middle east history
i know what i know but i also know that
i don't know
in what way it is biased um that it
it is obviously so fiercely fought over
that it's
one has to be very cautious of what they
think they know
but my sense is that there are
at least four examples
of islamic states
attempting to modernize and making
substantial progress
on that goal before being
bucked back to a uh
a more religious form of governance
and therefore a more conservative
interpretation
of the obligations of citizens
um and you know in the 20th century the
ones that i spot
are maybe most obviously
turkey and ataturk's modernization
but also mozadek in
iran it's going to be
controversial but saddam hussein as evil
a human being
as he was there is a story to be told
about
what form iraq was taking under his rule
and what happened as a result
of our deposing him
and sadat in egypt a very different
example
but all of these things suggest
a sort of a tendency towards
modernization of the islamic world that
then is overwhelmed
by geopolitical forces
that may have nothing to do with
religion but that
religion is you know maybe it's even an
analog of what you and i both fear
is going to happen in the u.s where um
the
pretense of uh ubiquitous white
supremacy is going to
create white supremacy right
so what do you think am i right that uh
islam
would probably modernize through
whatever mechanism
uh if it were not constantly up against
geopolitics um i think that
because of the tools within islam
to update interpretations i think that a
lot more people
would be a lot less afraid
to offer up um modernizing
um uh conceptions of
of faith right now and of course for a
long time
uh muslims have been you know suffocated
by fear first fear of
violent autocratic rulers later
fear of the state itself
and throughout because
islam was born in
what we know today as arabia and
the culture of honor which i'll explain
in just a second
is fundamental to that culture
culturally there is an inbuilt
resistance to doing anything
uh innovative because
one always has to worry within this
culture of honor
of dishonoring your family
um the culture i mean honor you know to
american ears sounds like a wonderful
thing
but here we're talking about collective
shame
and it's one thing you know for an
individual
such as myself to go out and
write a book about the need for reform
and
and then you know propagate that message
uh
as an individual but one of the things
that my own mother
had to contend with as i was doing this
was the question
you know about her honor as a parent
and her honor as a muslim by raising
a daughter first of all yeah a daughter
not just a son but a daughter
who dared to ask these questions and
think for herself
so um i knew that even as i
was writing the book that this is
something my mother will be punished for
because you know she's my mother
and therefore ultimately responsible for
me in this
mindset right so the real challenge
i think brett to modernizing the
practice of islam
is not the religion itself
it is what i have called in my first
book
fundamentalism not fundamentalism
but the privilege of
considering yourself as an arab
the founder of islam and therefore
the ability to pull rank and this is
what
saudi arabia does time
and again that you know
we muslims have just blithely
given the saudis the authority to
consider themselves the custodians
of the two main most important
uh kind of institutions you know
within islam and
because those institutions are located
in saudi arabia
but just because islam was founded there
so what look at what these people are
doing
in the name of god and yet
again you know this fundamentalism
is something we don't even think about
this is what i'm trying to get muslims
and more are
thinking about it why saudi arabia
why give them that authority what if
this is not an idea that's going to take
off anytime soon i assure you but
what if muslims boycotted the hajj
until the saudis began to treat
people foreign workers women
jews shia muslims
minorities in other words within their
own state
decently and what if we boycotted the
hajj
which takes place in saudi arabia in
mecca obviously
until such time as saudi arabia stopped
supporting the genocide
of the uyghur muslims in china
this is the kind of thing that we don't
even allow ourselves to think about
because uh it's just too frightening
so actually this uh you know again
i am not a scholar of the middle east
i'm
uh you know i'm a layperson
in this regard because i guess everyone
is unless you
have special understanding but it seems
to me and i was going to raise the
question of saudi arabia but you
raise it much more directly than i would
have
the accident of saudi arabia
being central and the possibly
non-accident
of islam being location
focused is conspiring with
geopolitics because of course saudi
arabia has become
so wealthy and so powerful due to its
alliances with the west which are of
course
largely about uh about fossil fuels
that that accident of history of there
being
uh a useless substrate buried under
saudi arabia that suddenly became
you know the core of 20th century power
and the monuments of islam and the
pilgrimage is heading towards this place
and even
i find something important about the
idea
that muslims multiple times a day
are orienting themselves physically in
the direction of saudi arabia
that all of this has a kind of
centralizing
effect on the thought process which
means
that if i mean it might be even a
blessing and a curse
if i can use that term in this context
because to the extent that uh
you and those who are aligned with you
in hoping to moderate modernize islam
are successful that the
tendency towards a centralized view
of the religion might more effectively
cause that to spread through what is in
fact
a muslim diaspora
but it works the other way too which is
that to the extent that
geopolitical forces conspire against
modernization
the resistance to modernizing is
is more networked by virtue of the
connection
of muslims to to a particular patch of
land
well let me tell you one other thing
that's going on
because you lay out you know a couple of
potential directions
the third direction which might actually
might fit with the first one namely the
modernizing of islam but i think it's a
tragedy what i'm about to
reveal is that um
the uh adherence to even identifying
with islam
is plummeting in many parts
of the muslim world uh
middle east states and even iran now one
would
perhaps not be surprised by that in iran
given theocracy given
imposition and you know no human being
actually takes well to being imposed
upon
but even in those parts of the world
that would otherwise quote stick with
islam
as a way of sticking it to western
colonizers
aren't doing that anymore and a whole
new
generation is beginning to just let go
of any loyalty to islam and it's
something that
i think a lot of muslims are in denial
about because again they recognize
that their own identities
are going to have to be challenged if
they're going to
allow for you know fresh air to come
into the practice of islam
but in the course of selfishly
protecting
their own identities they're allowing
the very source of that identity
islam itself to be thrown out the window
when the reality is you really can
have a win-win here where
you know you have something more like a
reform islam like we have in america
reform judaism
where a whole new generation can
identify with it
but identify in ways that have integrity
to them
you know uh there are
um avenues within islam
to promote environmentalism to promote
animal welfare even the well-being of
dogs
that are traditionally thought to be
toxic nudges as it said in arabic dirty
and spiritual dirty spiritually dirty
not merely physically dirty
but i can tell you that i see out there
facebook pages and initiatives that
people write to me about
in which a new generation is
taking the reins of what islam means to
them
and really and truly making it
meaningful to meaningful enough to
address
today's issues
those who live in societies where
they're free enough
to be able to smuggle that into their
lives is where
this is happening those who don't live
in free enough societies to do that
is where islam is dying wow
well that is fascinating
and i do see a
crystal clear hazard which is if what
you have
is a choice between um
a primitive primitive islam that is
adapted to
a world we no longer live in and
pure secularism that you will run the
risk
in the islamic world of going
from the one hazard to what we are now
seeing in the west which is kind of
a spiritual chaos
that i think is about to jeopardize
everything we have accomplished
right and really the right thing to do
and it's a very hard sell because for
some reason people are very attached to
you know who the discoverers were of
particular things and i don't get this
at all because
you know as a scientist i know full well
that the enlightenment was not a jewish
project
but i don't find the slightest bit of
embarrassment
in taking those tools as my own as
the birthright of every human and
wielding them to the best effect
i can and my sense is okay
so whatever population you came from
didn't
come up with the enlightenment or it had
a different enlightenment the tradition
has now died out because of historical
facts so what
take the tools and learn to wield them
in the interest
of what's right and don't worry so much
about
who discovered them right the fact is
most of us didn't discover anything
and we're using tools that we inherited
from either our
own ancestors or somebody else's but we
are also
part of one human lineage and if we
just simply could glimpse for even a
moment the way we are jeopardized
together the way we are vulnerable
together
and that it's going to take everything
we've got right if we put aside our
petty differences
and we simply say well what is the best
shot we have at getting through the next
500 years
right that's still a hard project even
if you put our differences aside
it's still a hard project in light of
the challenge that we have created for
ourselves with
technology and industrialization and we
can do it
but i don't think we are gonna do it if
we are
fighting each other over
you know bronze age distrust
uh and you know an obsession with genes
that doesn't even mention them because
nobody
at the time these texts were written
knew anything about genes right that's
really what this is this is the genes
fighting each other
using us as tools and throwing us away
and
we need to modernize but you know i
think
you know if there's an error that i
remember from
the intellectual tradition that i grew
up with it was the sense
that secularism was the answer
right that as soon as we all wake up to
the glory of
you know our secular selves that the
problems will be solved and i think we
now know enough to realize that that
actually leaves a gaping hole
that people fill with nonsense and
it creates uh a nonsensical battle
from which no one will emerge that in
fact
we can't go back to the traditional um
view and we can't abandon the view
entirely we have to create something
that is actually up to the challenge of
modernity but
honors the traditions from which we come
exactly right um at least in my view
exactly right
and i love brett that uh by the way do
you consider yourself an atheist
i never say that word about myself and
there's a reason that i don't
it's not you know i think my sense is
that almost anybody who draws the
distinction
if they heard me say what i believe
would classify me as one because i don't
believe that there is anything
supernatural there's no reason to
hypothesize it
but i don't say that i'm an atheist
because
atheist now carries baggage it's an
affirmative kind of belief
exactly and the atheists have uh
shouldered that burden very poorly in my
opinion they have
they have uh you know they have had a
religious
uh fervor about them for doing away
with other traditions that is completely
inappropriate
and it has resulted in some of our uh
smartest atheists let's say completely
missing the fact
that religion is serving a function that
much is obvious
evolutionarily and so we are obligated
not to pretend it's a mistake which is
what the new atheists have done so
no i don't call myself an atheist but
probably everybody else
would be likely to see me that way sure
fair enough and i
again you know really appreciate the
fact that you've distinguished between
the label and the baggage that goes the
assumptions that go with that label
uh which is exactly you know the the
issue that i have with with labeling
people
that said i love the fact that you've
pointed out
that we are in a state of spiritual
chaos and i think more than just
chaos i think it's a void that you know
politics
whether it is the cultism of q anon
or the cultism of blm
uh have swooped in to fill
so you know though organized religion is
on the decline
um that doesn't mean religion is on the
decline
um there and that really does suggest to
me
that you know as human beings the the
the function
that organized religion has played for
us is a function that speaks to a
deep seeded perhaps even genetic
need of ours right the need for
belonging
the need for community uh
and frankly the need for identity
but the other thing that
religion i think has done which i
really had didn't pay attention to until
quite recently
is that it gave human beings a way
of cooperating with one another outside
of the immediate family that there was
uh an ability or a reason or an
incentive to trust people outside of
your immediate family for better or for
worse not everybody deserved that trust
obviously but to trust people outside of
your immediate family
in order to cooperate on a wider scale
in order to build societies institutions
and ultimately civilizations
um seems to me
um that once again we have
among the cultists you know the cults
that we've got raging right now
we have a kind of a blind trust for one
another
but i don't see them exactly interested
in anything that cooperates
uh with others you know i see
merely again us versus them
which religions organize religions
traditional religions
easily lapse into you i totally
understand that
but there is a larger vision it seems to
me
within traditional religions that the
cults
of our time simply don't have
am i being honestly am i being a little
too rosy about uh
the religions that we've previously uh
belonged to
no i this is a distinction i i have
trouble
convincing people of but what we have
is traditions that have stood the test
of time
about which we can infer certain things
must be true
right it is impossible that something
as durable as islam
is not functional that doesn't make it
good or bad
and it will have both components but we
know that it has worked to get people
through history were it a simple error
the way the new atheists would have it
then those people who believed
everything that muslims believed
except for doctrine would have an
advantage they'd waste less of their
time
and they don't clearly or at least they
haven't and so
we know that ancient traditions served a
purpose
what we don't know is that they continue
to serve a purpose presumably
the amount the degree to which they
serve people will have changed over time
in a way that we can't track
and beyond that
any new belief system we will not be
able to say the same thing
in other words if we came up with a
modern
version of an ancient religion or
a novel religion we can't say that it
stands the test of time and so we don't
know whether it serves long-term
interests or not
so we are stuck in a in a bit of a
predicament which is that the tools
that fashion a coherent belief system
are selection and selection takes time
and so
we cannot use that tool we have to use
something better on the other hand
you know your your description
of religions as
creating a basis for trust beyond the
family
i believe this is literally accurate and
then in fact one thing that we cannot
see
is that selection endowed us with an
understanding of immediate family
because evolutionarily speaking there is
a lot to be gained by understanding to
whom you are related
and how related you are and to whom you
are not directly related but should
behave as if you are
so for example in-laws right are close
family but not for genetic reasons
you're effectively related through your
descendants
to your in-laws which is a a very
interesting
evolutionary phenomenon but
in effect these communities religious
communities
do extend trust beyond the family but
really what you're looking at is
extended families
these are lineages and so the genetic
basis for that trust
is there up until a certain point at
which
increasingly modern mixtures of people
result in the establishment of trust
between populations that may not be
closely related and so there's a new
evolutionary question which is if i
200 years ago being in a jewish
community somewhere
would have extended trust to other jews
that i did not know myself to be related
to but in fact i was
in effect more closely related to them
than to others
can we now take those same parameters
and float them without the genetic
connection
right in other words can people who have
no genetic basis
for trust stability come to trust each
other
and then hopefully the answer to that
question is yes
and if the question if the answer to
that question is yes
then the ultimate question is why not
the human lineage
right we are in fact so if if these
belief systems
evolved in the context of lineages
fighting lineages and therefore needing
to extend trust in order to survive
through time
right the threat from the outside is
what causes you to view
others as aligned well we are all
threatened from the outside we are now
threatened
we've seen the enemy and it is us right
our technology
is going to do us in if we don't figure
out how to collaborate
so the question maybe the
the ultimate question is can we
view ourselves as one lineage fighting
an external threat that is not human in
nature or if it is human it is us
um i suspect the answer to that is yes
whether we will get there i don't know
well and
and this is why brett um i mean i'm
working with exactly that question
in uh leading the moral courage project
i know that the phrase moral courage
easily
connotes uh the idea of speaking truth
to power
but the the problem with just leaving it
at that is
you know it suggests that there's that
your truth the one
that you are speaking is the only truth
worth considering
and moreover if you're speaking it to
power that must suggest that you
yourself have no power
that power is always external to you
when the reality is that you know
those of all of us are born with brains
and therefore born with that primitive
part that gives rise to the ego
and the ego if we're not aware of its
machinations
is at least in my view the most
pervasive most pernicious power
and most universal power that exists
and it makes us cling
to quote truth believing that we must
lest we be weak lest we be uh you know
wiped out um
and makes us believe that therefore we
can't be listening
to where other people are coming from
uh this is i think what it means to have
moral courage
in a time as urgent as ours
quite simply it means listening instead
of labeling
or maybe i should get more realistic
here listening
before labeling you know
but but it's because there is a
biological impulse
to feel threatened that
we've actually got to figure out ways to
tame
that impulse and i i it seems to me that
we will not
figure out enduring ways
if we don't believe
that perspectives other than our own
are worth or worth hearing out
so this uh
fits very closely with uh a set of
thoughts i've had
i'll just uh lay them out briefly you
can tell me what you think
i have noticed the following thing in
traversing across lines that maybe
i wouldn't be expected to traverse
across
when one thinks independently one
ends up building kind of a
personal epistemology and that personal
epistemology comes with terms
that will have been either invented or
will have been redefined so that they
are sharper
and what tends to be true
of people who have generated such an
epistemology
is that they will very frequently forget
that they've done it in other words they
will
create this way of understanding the
world that is self-consistent
and it will sound like it is deliverable
in the common language
english in my case but if you take two
such people
and you put them together and you say
okay now
talk about what's true they will very
frequently run a foul
of their personal redefinition of the
world for self-consistency because they
won't realize that the other person has
done it also
and the other person will simply sound
wrong to them so
the way to get around this is to spend
time and i i think it's completely
unavoidable it is necessary
when you are dealing with people who
have thought independently
for sufficiently long to have their own
world view
you have to spend it's often weeks
learning
to hear the other person as they are
actually intending
to be heard and teaching them to hear
you the same way
right so there's this process of saying
okay when i say the word sympathy this
is actually what i mean
right i don't mean what people typically
mean
and when you get past that what you
typically discover
is that you know you have the most
fascinating
puzzle imaginable which is you have all
of these minds
which are you know constrained
by the perceptual and cognitive tools
that each of us
have which are highly idiosyncratic in
many ways
and they're also limited to whatever
experiences we have had in the world our
own personal histories
dramatically affect what we think is
true
and then you can you know we have this
marvelous tool of language that allows
us to compare notes but in order to
compare notes
you sort of need to build the rosetta
stone for each conversation
and that's not a process that can be
quick right to the extent that these
world views are deep
that process is slow once you get there
though
and you sort of have extended
sufficient trust for somebody else to
compel you of
their little glossary so that you can
understand them as they need to be
understood
there's a tremendous benefit to be had
in teaming up now the problem the fly in
the ointment of all of this
is that it is contingent on the fact
that you are in a good faith environment
right so if everybody in the room is
extending to
others a sense that what you believe
is sure to be self-consistent and or
sure to be largely self-consistent and
that there is benefit
in trading world views and then seeing
if anything new emerges
that's great but you can't do it in any
old room where
somebody may be there you know selling
something or whatever they might be
doing
um all right so the question then is
if a does that model dovetail with what
you've experienced and b
if so what does it imply about the
project that you're
suggesting uh a it does
um uh dovetail with what i've
experienced um
it takes time to figure out
first of all what do we have enough in
common
that we can start from a place of trust
before diving into difference
but i must tell you that i'm not as
hung up about the need for patience
as maybe what you've suggested here's
why
my many years of walking this
complicated earth
tells me that every single
one of us is more than meets the eye
we are as i say and don't label me the
only
the only label that i can stand by that
captures all of us is
the label plural we are all plurals
and let me bounce this off of you
if we got into the habit right of
entering into potentially contentious
conversations
conversations in which we know there's
going to be disagreement
but we started it off by saying look we
don't know much about each other we
probably only really know that we
disagree on x
issue but the one thing that i can count
on
i would say to you brett is that you are
so much more than what i think
i know about you so am i
i'm so much more than what you assume
about me and
can we agree therefore that in this
conversation i'm not going to judge you
or
judge the totality of who you are
based on your position
on this particular issue and could you
extend to me the same courtesy
if we established an a ground rule
like that first of all is that
too idealistic is that a habit we can
actually get into in order to begin
uh making you know um
making a conversation more constructive
than it might otherwise be
so it's funny um i had almost forgot to
mention it
the uh
there is a small community of people i
don't even know exactly know what its
boundaries are
but that was united by
our friendship with mike brown mike
brown
used to hold a uh
a gathering he called science camp where
he would
bring scientists to a particular island
and we would talk to each other about
what we thought were true was true doing
exactly the
sort of thing you and i are describing
here and there was a thing that we had
called double island rule
the double island rule because we were
meeting on double island
was that when somebody says something
that sounds stupid you know
they wouldn't be in the conversation if
they were stupid therefore
you are obligated to imagine that what
they have said
makes sense relative to some framework
and you're obligated to look for it
right leaping to the conclusion that
because somebody has said something
preposterous
um that they are obviously not making
sense wouldn't wouldn't be a reasonable
thing to do in that context now you
can't apply
this rule just any old place right
lots of people say lots of stupid stuff
but
in the context where you have uh curated
the discussion so that everybody there
knows what sense sounds like at the
point people stop making sense
there's typically a reason for it and
very frequently it comes down to one of
these
uh glossary comparisons or something
like that
so um i i i love your approach to this
which is
you know all wise people recognize
that you that i might be the central
player in my story
but that you are surely the central
player in your story
and therefore i need to correct the
discussion for the fact that
if each participant is having that
experience
that you know and this is some place
very important to me we are actually
having a conversation that exists
between us the important thing about
this conversation
is not what happened in your head that
could go on to be important you could go
on to do something with it
likewise i could go on to do something
with it but the primary import of this
conversation
is that you and i have created an
emergent space between us
in which we have reached an
understanding right and it contains
pieces of what i think and pieces of
what you think
and it seems to be hanging together in
the middle in the sense that we seem to
agree
on important things that uh are
enlightening in their own right
and it's very hard
i think to create a desire to do that
for people who have too frequently been
rewarded for
uh let's say zero-sum competition
in discussion where typically they feel
good if they score points in a
discussion uh or if
they get lots of um kudos for
having one-upped somebody right but if
your experience is that actually if i
if i just simply have faith that there
is an emergent feature to this
conversation
and i work to enhance the emergent part
of the conversation
that it tends to be good for me in ways
that i can't even put my finger on so i
don't need to worry about it
well and and i think that it tends to be
good
uh in a way that i can and i think most
people if they think about it this way
would easily be able to put their finger
on which is this
look if if you if you want to be heard
whatever your message the surest way the
most reliable way to get a fair
hearing is to give one first
not because there's any magic in that
but because
there is a biological process
here where brett if i am
asking you sincere questions about where
you're coming from
and i'm listening to understand not to
win
because there's no need to turn a
perfectly good discussion
into a debate
and i continue to ask you authentic
questions from a place of curiosity and
not judgment
whatever emotional defenses you may have
walked into the conversation with
because you knew that we disagreed on
something
hence the high emotional defenses now
your emotional defenses can lower
and that in turn means that the clatter
and the clutter in your head
of wanting to poke holes in whatever
argument i'm about to make
can at the very least diminish
and you'll have more space to hear
where i'm coming from exactly because
i've given you the space to be heard
um again i'm not saying that
you know every conversation is going to
go swimmingly as a result but i will
tell you
i've uh i'm the co-executive producer
of a documentary coming out soon about
a young woman uh one of my mentees uh
from nyu
who um
advocated changing the mississippi state
flag
particularly the confederate battle
emblem in that flag
and uh you know her movement won this
long-standing goal just a few months ago
but in the process
she launched an incendiary protest
and of course received a ton of hate for
it
and then she decided
she's going to try something different
and she tried exactly what you and i
have just described
and she sat down with not just
a supporter of the confederate flag but
somebody
who belongs to the sons of confederate
veterans
okay and she started by asking him
a genuine question heartfelt
how does that flag make you feel
so not a brain buster
not gotcha just how does it make you
feel
and he replied makes me feel at home
he asked her how does it make you feel
she said like i'm not at home
even though i am and the conversation
got underway in earnest and during that
time
the flag supporter uh louis is his name
realized something he realized that he
actually cared
more about genesis than he did about the
flag itself
and afterwards i asked him what the hell
man like how did that happen
and he said honestly uh i've
just never experienced respect from
anybody on the other side
like i did today
it is it is that it is that
simple not saying that it's easy to show
respect
to somebody with whom you profoundly
disagree on something that you're
passionate about
but when you do offer it
it's amazing what can happen
and for those who assume i have nothing
to say to somebody who must
obviously be a racist let me tell you
not in that conversation not after that
conversation
but about 10 months later
lewis through his own volition
pulled down the confederate flag that
was flying in his backyard
neatly folded it up and put it in a box
called
things of the past and
between that conversation and that
moment
he not only joined the new flag movement
but this is so beautifully deliciously
mississippi
he became a mentor
to the leaders of the movement teaching
them
how to protect themselves with guns
how to work a gun how to clean a gun how
to maintain it how to get it registered
he was their guru and let me tell you
that gave them the peace of mind to go
boldly forth
that is a beautiful story it is a really
beautiful story and it resonates
for so many different reasons um and the
confederate flag is the perfect thing
to be at the heart of that story because
anybody who has
um engaged southerners
who favor that flag knows that it is not
simply and in general it's not even
flown by people proudly
as an assertion of uh racial
dominance that's right it is flown
as a symbol of southern
identity for certain people right
heritage heritage now those of us
who you know from the north or black
or whatever rightly understand that flag
as a threat right to something
important and so you can just see how
the conversation
bogs down in the assumption of what the
other must be thinking
and and the key word there assumption
right
the assumption and so the other thing
that i would say
is i have not lived that story over the
confederate flag
but i have lived many analogs of this
story where
there is somebody i'm not supposed to be
able to talk to
and something in me that i
think others would regard as perverse
finds that challenge irresistible
right i love to talk to such people and
when i do
it's not every time but it's certainly
the majority of times
it is readily possible to cross that
bridge
it is frequently delightful what you
find on the other side it's not
typically enlightened they may not feel
that i am enlightened
but the discovery of the humanity on the
other side of a bridge that's supposed
to be
uncrossable is so rewarding
right it is so reifying
of the sense of humanity and possibility
and optimism and all of those things
that i swear to you it's addictive
and i'm i know i'm talking to somebody
who must feel that same thing
i do and if only
you know i've said it in various ways
i've said
that doing away with
your own bigotry is like giving yourself
a huge
raise right you don't know what cost
you're paying
walking around the world with bigotry
it's it's costing you
every hour of every day in ways you
don't have any idea about
until you get rid of it and when you get
rid of it you'll discover
people are more interesting they're more
fun they're more surprising
and uh you know it really is like
some giant raise that just makes you
freer than you were before
life becomes an adventure it does yeah
and
and if people understood that like you
know if you could give yourself a raise
a monetary raise would you do it
of course you would right if you could
give yourself a raise that just didn't
happen to pay in money but it paid in
something else that's
more valuable would you do that of
course you would well here's one
you know to the extent that you have
bigotry right
just cancel it just try it out try it
out for a week right
see if you're not a happier person and
see if you don't feel smarter
frankly right because these biases they
don't help you think clearly
right is that so true they're they're
they're about
fact they prevent you from thinking
right you know
from actually thinking that is exactly
exactly right
that's a lovely story what is the name
of the documentary it's called
mississippi turning
oh good one and you know some people may
think that as a result of
the new flag and all that it implies
that uh
you know mississippi is turning as in
spoiling right and other people will see
mississippi
mississippi
turning for the better so either way
we've got ourselves covered
love it it's a it's a deep play on words
um
and the uh did i glean that the
the protagonist uh or one of the
protagonists of your story her name was
genesis genesis yes genesis all right
well that's interesting too
um yeah okay that's that's fantastic i
look forward to this
this documentary um it uh
maybe it will succeed in making the
point to many about what might be on the
other side and we can stop
this nonsense of accusing people of
being
deplorable or
whatever it is that people somehow
imagine it's hard to once you
stop doing that it's hard to even
understand
what is in people's minds about it
all right are there other things that
you think we should cover we've been out
this uh
good couple hours here we have i've
enjoyed every minute of it um
i wonder if there's any interest we're
far
well somewhat far out of it now but um
in
tackling what happened on capitol hill
on january the 6th
and whether you know sort of what i've
learned over the course of uh
my journey as a reform-minded muslim uh
teaches me anything about you know how
to how to de-radicalize i mean i
i really don't think that i have
anything earth-shattering
to say but inconvenient to say sure like
the fact that you know
uh in many cases
the jihadists or ex-jihadists whom i
came into touch with
um simply wanted to be heard
you know they they wanted somebody to
take an interest
in why they felt the way they did
um because not only were they rejected
by mainstream society whatever that was
in their context
whether it was in france or whether it
was in
you know in uh in jordan um
but also their own parents who expected
these young men to
toe a certain line that didn't make
sense for their lives
so they felt squeezed between two
pressures
two forces neither one of which actually
gave a dam
about what they were thinking and
feeling
and what's weird to i think our
sensibilities in this part of the world
is that
when they stepped into these dens of
indoctrination
uh you know led by radical imams
those imams said to them
in different ways um
ask anything you want come as you are
we accept you as
you are today and that is a
level of acceptance that they simply did
not experience
in any other aspect of their lives
okay um i think i see where you're
headed but do you want to draw the
connection to
uh january 6th
i mean look yeah i don't know that
i uh i don't know that there is
a scholarly connection to be made here
i wonder and it is truly a question
if some even many
i'm not suggesting most certainly not
all but some or many
of the individuals who took part in that
riot
uh made us an outlet
for feeling relevant
um you know it's interesting you know i
watched a lot of that footage
and i watched it slowly and i watched it
repeatedly
and i don't want to make too much of
this bread but i will tell you that i
saw
it the footage uh gave me a sense of
deja vu
because i got the sense that there was
this um
this rampage for a sense of glory
as aimless as it was because once they
got there what were they gonna do
but a rampage uh for a sense of glory
that
i experienced when my own uh
book launches one in amsterdam and one
in the second largest city of indonesia
was crashed or were crashed by
militant jihadis who
didn't know what to do once they arrived
in the case of amsterdam
i remember saying you know sit down
this is my house right now you are my
guests right now
you will sit down and when i am done
you will have the chance to have your
say
half of them sat down the other half
didn't
but i looked at the ones who were
sitting down and it's as if
these kids that's what they were at the
time
simply wanted guidance you know
so well i don't know ultimately what i'm
i'm implying here but one thing i will
tell you there's a
and you may have heard of her a uh
political scientist political
psychologist actually by the name of
karen stenner
who has written a fantastic
fascinating book called the
authoritarian dynamic
and one of the big points she makes in
that book is that
the way a way
to curb this what we consider
um some of us senseless violence
is to understand
people as they are not as we want them
to be
not as we wish them to be but as
they are and that does mean
again inviting
them to tell their stories in a way that
allows them to be vulnerable which means
no immediate judgments
and one last thing i'll say is that it
is only when
the jihadis who felt heard
uh or i should say this it is only when
jihadis whom i spoke with
felt heard and this was long before they
met me or i met them
that they decided to leave
the cult of jihadism
something to think about yeah no i i uh
believe me this is uh this is
relevant in many ways one of them highly
personal
so the the incident that uh brought me
to public attention
involved a protest at my classroom
50 students that i had never met
and there is a part of that
that i remember absolutely
vividly the memory is as if it was
yesterday full living color i can hear
the tones and the voices
there's a point at which i'm trying to
reason with these people
i'm not afraid i know that they've got
me wrong
and so i am proceeding to do
what i had not realized i had been
training for 14 years to do which
was to correct a confusion
that college students had in this case
the confusion was about me
and i i got the protesters
to engage me and i started trying to
make the point
that i want a world in which
no race is disadvantaged that i want
that as much as they do
but that i don't think they understand
where they are or what's going on or who
i
am and there are these two women
who engage me they clearly
had a sense for what sort of monster
they were
confronting and as i talked to them
i saw in their eyes i saw them realize
that the story they had been given
couldn't possibly be right whatever
might be wrong with me
it wasn't what they'd been told because
that wasn't who they were talking to
they were obviously talking to somebody
who was willing to engage and who didn't
seem to want
bad things and
the problem was not that i couldn't make
progress with them
in fact probably an hour or two and
we could have been very nearly on the
same page
the problem was that there was a force
that pulled them back
right they knew that if they came back
from this protest and said to the people
who had sent them
uh something's not right here that
doesn't sound like you told us he was
going to
that they were going to have a lot of
explaining to do
and that there were all kinds of
penalties deployed for people who did
question
the um the protesters who became rioters
their narrative
those who questioned it were humiliated
right
and so there are forces that prevent
people
from actually waking up and
so anyway that's one of the things that
we are up against
now with respect to the january 6th
protest at the capitol
i very definitely see that it was
many different people responding to
intense frustration
at a game that is rigged
and a story that is false now they
believe things
most of them maybe almost all of them
believe things
which i believe are provably false they
were acting on the basis of some of them
much of the q anon stuff as you describe
it is
very cultish and built around a
false understanding of the world on the
other hand
the story that was told about them
was also desperately false and we are
now coming to understand
just how false it was right so to the
extent
that many on the blue team think they
understand
there was an armed insurrection of the
capital
it was hell-bent on violence
against people and it
murdered a police officer it
came prepared to engage in kidnapping
well that's all false right the best
evidence we have now
is that they weren't armed despite the
fact that you might expect
them to have been armed that the
zip tie handcuffs were picked up by
protesters
inside the capitol and taken away to
prevent the police from using them
rather than they brought them with the
intent of kidnapping anyone
and the police officer who we were told
was killed beaten to death with a fire
extinguisher by protesters
apparently was not beaten by protesters
so i don't know the facts i don't know
if those facts will reverse again
but what i can say is what you have is
false stories upon false stories
resulting in people
thinking they know enough to render
judgments about others
that in fact they couldn't know enough
about we're all dealing
with a mechanism that tells us what's
true
which has demonstrated time and time
again that it is not reliable
and forces us into a
uh a false belief that we were present
that we saw it with our own eyes
and in any case um
what one does about this is unclear but
you can watch it unfold in real time as
people
try to establish a position that doesn't
get them in trouble that
you know rescues the uh
rescues them from the
uh concern of their friends that maybe
they don't believe the right things
people are constantly trying to find out
what they can say
that gets them off the hook that puts
them in the right position
and that that process makes us suckers
for those who wish to give us a false
story
about uh either who they are or who
our enemies are and it is
putting us in grave danger do you think
that um
that a community or tribe of
misfits is possible
i by definition you know uh misfits
don't necessarily uh have
enough in common to glue them together
except for the fact that they're all
misfits
could could it work of course of course
and um
this is a long-standing interest of mine
so i consider myself
a misfit i was always a misfit in school
i like the term
because it does not pass judgment on
whether it is you
or the system which is exactly broken
yeah so i think misfit is a is an
honorable
term and one can embrace it
there is a problem for misfits um
gathering and teaming up the problem
being that
in large measure if you're a misfit and
you make it out the other side you
typically have a strong independent
streak you may not have
a robust toolkit for
partnering and those with whom you
partner will be sufficiently different
that you run into these
self-definition uh you know different
glossary
that sort of problem however i
strongly believe that the answer has to
involve the misfits teaming up
that as a misfit that's a great deal of
fun
right that actually finding other
misfits it's much more interesting than
grouping with people who see the world
exactly as you do
and so i've i've played with two
terms in this regard one of them
uh i'm not sure i've ever spoken about
this publicly but
you know the the name of the podcast is
the dark horse podcast
and its purpose
uh was to highlight people
who you know the dark horse is a
benjamin
disraeli invention it's a horse on which
you do not know
how to bet because it was trained in
secret so you don't know what it's
capable of
right so dark horses come from nowhere
they challenge your expectations etc and
so the idea that there are dark horses
among us who
should be spotlighted so that we can
begin to understand
what they bring to the table is great
and so a stable of dark horses
is something that the podcast was meant
to discover and the other one
is a pack of lone wolves right
and i think these are all close
neighbors to the idea of a collection of
misfits
and frankly uh any one of them is good
enough for me but yes i think the
misfits have to figure out how to talk
to each other because
uh they're our only hope well
brett i'm uh proud and dare i say it
privileged
really to be part of your community of
misfits
i've just loved our time together me too
you are a true dark horse and
wait a minute was that no that wasn't
okay okay
yeah making sure you could you could
play that card but it's not going to
work out for you
have no desire to play that card no i
know you don't i know you don't all
right
um well this has been an absolute
delight
um where can people find you
a couple of places actually my own
website
is earshadmanji.com as you know i
run the moral courage project and that's
at moralcourage.com
and of course i'm on social um
on twitter you can find me at
earshadmanji and
uh yeah we'll leave it there all right
well i mispronounced your name up front
your shot manji
oh you know what i i anglicize it
because
you know it's it's uh it's now a habit
but i
you pronounce it beautifully from the
get-go
oh you're chad banjo okay i didn't
always pronounce it i feel good about it
sir all right i will uh i will get to
that later today
the fat on the back that is um okay
uh well i think that's all for this
episode of darkos it's been a
delight and i look forward to seeing the
documentary
that you mentioned and we'll send it to
you our next conversation
all right be well everyone thanks your
shad
be well take care and stay vertical
indeed
good advice all right bye now
you